well hello there everyone coming to you
from home today
this is April 16th 2020 web presentation
for the Eastern Ohio grazing council
we're gonna talk to you today a little
bit about grazing terminology and
definitions and I gotta admit when I
started thinking about doing this topic
it was because I just come back from the
western Pennsylvania grazing conference
and they had talked about some things
there that I wasn't quite sure what the
definition was and so I figured how
better than to look up definitions or
try to figure out what those things were
and to also put them in presentation
form for all of you and then as I did
the presentation I thought boy you know
maybe we're going a little too basic but
I'll tell you as I did the research and
kind of look through some other
terminology I really found out that I
learned a lot myself had some some
grazing epiphanies along the way and
really enjoyed putting this one together
I will say that that I put a really big
breeze and take two together and I ran
through it once and it was gonna be
almost an hour long so I've cut it way
down and we'll probably have to pick up
some other grazing terminology somewhere
on down the road but we'll go ahead and
get started ok first I wanted to talk
about the management definitions or the
management descriptions of grazing but
first let me say that there's no real
written down definition of a lot of the
terms we're going to discuss here and so
you're getting the Clint vini version of
each of these terms or words that we use
and I may not be exactly right but it's
the best that I can find and the best
that I can put together certainly we can
do some more research and some more
thinking and talking about what each one
of these terms mean
to us as we go through this presentation
but first one on the list their
management intensive grazing will always
be shown as capital M small I capital G
and and that's because when Jim garish
coined the phrase management intensive
grazing he wanted all the focus for
intensity to be on management and not on
grazing we want our management to be
intensive and not the grazing it's
really easy to have intensive grazing
you put too many animals into small
space and leave them for too long a time
and that's intensive grazing or what we
would call over grazing but we want our
management to be intensive it's the the
management that we make intensive
grazing so management tents and grazing
is all about the forage and letting it
get to the correct height before we
graze it removing the animals when they
get to the residue we're shooting for so
bluegrass 2 which is 3 inches which your
grass fescue 4 inches residue and
removing the animals moving them on to
another paddock they're being rotation
involved they're rotating to a new panic
typically the stays in a paddock would
be less than three days because we don't
want the animals to to regrade plants
that are starting to regrow after your
grazing event we don't return to a
paddock until the height is where we our
target is for entering a paddock and
we'll skip a paddock if we need to if
the Ford isn't grown enough to be able
to put the livestock in then management
intensive grazing takes in stockpiling
and winter feeding and and really as it
scores focus was on reduction of cost
for grazing and for farming in general
and also increased production per acre
as management ends in grazing we do see
sometimes that our individual production
or per cow or purse tier has gone down a
little bit but our overall production
per acre has has actually gone up so mr.
garrison wrote a great book
that same name management intensive
grazing if you're interested it's out
there and it goes through all those
things while we're on that same thought
I hope that these terms here we'll be
putting into a future presentation I'm
probably gonna call it stepping up our
grazing game and we're gonna go a little
more in depth into some of these so I'm
trying to hold myself back and not put
everything into each one of these the
next one they're mob grazing this is
something that I've said that I've been
doing for years and as I did the
research for this presentation I kind of
realized it maybe maybe I'm doing it
wrong or maybe maybe it's not what I
exactly want to be do it every time but
mob grazing typically uses high stocking
densities per acre so a stocking density
of a hundred thousand pounds per acre
plus for those of you that don't know
how we calculate that stocking density
is is how many pounds of animal is on
that acre so if we want to get a hundred
thousand pounds per acre of stocking
density and we've got 10,000 pounds of
cattle and our herd we need to split
that acre up ten times to be able to get
a hundred thousand pounds per acre of
stock density so we won we've got to
have enough forage out there to graze
and keep those animals on for for a day
and at least split up ten times but also
we've got to split that acre up ten
times to get that stocking density mob
grazing incorporates longer rest periods
and things really the at the core of mob
grazing it's it's thinking about putting
all of our livestock in one big group or
mob
so our growing steers are finished
steers our calves our cows are stalkers
if we've got other grazing livestock
putting them all out there in one big
group tall grass grazing kind of follows
along with that we would be grazing
stuff that's kind of over mature maybe
has gone to seed at Brown in the hope of
tall grass grazing is when we go those
ultra high stocking densities that
livestock are trampling the Fords that's
over mature returning it back to the
soil and they're grazing the vegetative
parts of the sward that we have out
there the real issue with tall grass
grazing is we're allowing the forage to
get over mature and as we think about
grazing we think about it being a solar
panel out there and collecting sunlight
and if we've let that Ford to get over
mature then it's snow we're collecting
the sunlight that it could be hearing
Easter Ohio we only get seven eight
months of growing season we don't want
to let that solar panel get dirty or
shaded I guess is the way to think about
it we want it to stay green and growing
and vegetative that may have been the
biggest Epiphany I had while I was doing
the research for this presentation is
that at times I'm letting things get too
tall that was the way I knew how to do
mob grazing was let it get too tall with
a lot of forage out there per acre and
in doing so I'm hurting myself in the
production in because I'm not keeping it
vegetative and keep it growing adaptive
grazing what else started in did because
I wanted to really know what adaptive
grazing was over the western
Pennsylvania grazing conference Alan
Williams talked a lot about adaptive
grazing and it really didn't know the
definition so to me as I did some
research and there are some really
awesome YouTube videos there's a whole
series out there on adaptive grazing
that Alan Lance did so it's core it's
kind of rolling management and some
grazing mob grazing ultra high stocking
density grazing kind of rolling those
all in together and and it's just what
it says it's adaptive so at times were
at low stocking densities depending on
our goals at times we're at high
stocking densities depending on you know
we may have a problem we'd we're trying
to mob up and graze hard or or trample
we may have tall grass that we need to
be able to put them at a high stocking
density to get them to actually eat
consume and trample that forage but
adaptive grazing is adapting our grazing
management to our current situations the
seasons how the grass is growing and
what our herd needs and
and it may have role in a little bit of
the holistic management we'll talk about
in just minute rotational grazing this
is one that I think is kind of a slang
term for management intensive grazing
but to me rotational grazing is
somewhere that we've got a set number of
paddocks and we rotate through them and
a set number at Daiso really we're
rotating by the calendar I've set up a
lot of these systems designed a lot of
these systems the farmer usually goes
something like well I can only move them
once a week so we set up a system with
five to seven pastures they move them
once a week there's really not any
thought put into the forage it's all put
into the calendar that to me is a
rotational grazing system where we're
just rotating based on the calendar and
in continuous if sets not grazing we
talk about continuous we're talking
about an area where the animals are just
out there loose there's no real rotation
to it they may be their season-long they
may be their month-long really any time
we leave animals in a paddock more than
let's say 10 days we're at that sort of
continuous grazing level because our
utilization rates have fallen to a point
that they're the same as if we would
have left them there all season al-bait
if there's a rotation of any kind it's
better than continuous and being there
all season but anytime we've been in a
paddock probably more than ten days
we're getting to that continuous grazing
kind of situation then regenerative
agriculture that's kind of the new term
out there if I had to pick a kind of a
face of regenerative agriculture it's a
guy by the name of Gabriel in North
Dakota but the regenerative agriculture
folks really take soil health into
account a lot of them are cropland
producers that are integrating livestock
into their cropping rotations as as Gabe
Brown talks about it he's got
regenerative agriculture right there on
his ranch side as you go into his place
in North Dakota and one of the things he
said in one of the presentations I
listened to was you know we wanted to
talk about being sustainable and I
didn't want to be sustainable I wanted
to be regenerative I want
our ranch to get better than what it was
so that's sort of the thought for
regenerative agriculture is they want to
regenerate and it's also partially
realizing that our soils are degraded
they're degraded from the time we
arrived here and we wanted to put them
back to as good or better a state than
they were when we arrived and then
holistic management created by a man
named Allen savory in Africa but also
has some some interest in southwest
desert areas of this country but
holistic management is a whole
management system and it can be for
wildlife it can be for grazing animals
incorporate some of the high stocking
density stuff that's where some of the
mob grazing stuff comes from adaptive
grazing certainly includes some of the
holistic management stuff but it was
really created for some of the brittle
climates and in managing those brittle
climates and getting them to produce
forage again so they're there again
there's a really good book Allen wrote
Allan savory wrote about holistic
management it's a very very hard read
but it's a very good read on what
holistic management is and it's kind of
managing all the parts of your grazing
operation or of your field or farm next
we're going to talk a minute about
pastures and the different terminology
we use for pastures so a paddock for
those under many different definitions I
think as we talk about grazing but to me
a paddock is the interior really fenced
areas in our large or a pasture area so
at home we have 14 paddocks then we can
infinitely break those paddocks up into
smaller areas that we should probably
call sales I usually call them breaks
but a paddock to me is a internally
fenced area inside our larger pasture
area so from that you can take a cell
cell being for me it's one day's grazing
or twelve hours worth of grazing I guess
it's it's your grazing durations
a time or length so if some of us is
selling a paddock would be the same
thing for some of its it's different
like I said I used the term brake
especially in a paddock where I've split
it up maybe three different times and
I've allowed them to walk back to water
for those that 24 hour or however many
hours that time is usually it's less
than three days I may give them breaks
within a paddock and allow them to walk
back to water as long as it's less than
three days from their strip grazing
strip grazing something we use in the
fall when we do stockpile grass
stockpile grazing strip grazing
typically is given animals a small strip
and then allowing them to walk back to
water and this may be for a month in the
winter time that we keep giving them
more strips and allowing to walk back to
water because we're really not concerned
with how much forage they're gonna be
picking at what they've already walked
over because we're not in the growing
season bale grazing sort of like strip
grazing with bales we have the bail set
stocked out there at 25 foot centers
typically we build temporary electric
fence around those bales and then we
move the temporary fence to allow the
livestock access to the bales so use a
lot in the western states we talked
about that a couple of presentations ago
for here in Ohio but is a good system
especially if we get frozen weather
creep grazing something we might do with
cows and calves we may build an area in
the fence so that the cows can her
calves can get to the next day's grazing
or next week's grazing to allow them to
kind of pick a better forage or or have
a better meal than what their mothers
are eating in the product that they're
in creep grazing can use a creep gate it
can use a raised area in the fan sir
simply the calves can go under the one
strand of wire to get to the next field
to creep graze leader follower grazing
sort of along that same line what we do
there is we're putting the animals that
are on a higher nutritional claim ahead
of the animals that don't need to be
let's think grass finishing steers in
the front paddock and cows in the second
pasture so the cows follow this the
grass finishing spear so the grass
finishing steers are only eating the
best and the cows are eating what's left
over or eating the rest before we move
them on
so the steers move ahead the cows fill
in the field that the steers were in and
then flash grazing is something we talk
about if we're Grace and say like
riparian areas that we fenced out so
streams creeks ponds places we might
only turn the cows in there for an hour
or two hours are very short duration so
they go in they graze and we get them
out of there before they lounge around
and before they have a chance degrade
that area like tamping down stream banks
or waiting in the ponds
those are areas that we would do flash
grazing we'll talk about forages here I
just kind of threw in some terms that
maybe everybody's not really up on and
also maybe some things that need a
little bit better definition to them so
a s'more the sward would be all of the
forages contained in our pasture or in a
paddock so our grasses legumes forbs
weeds everything that's out there that
is graze able is what we consider our
sward out there in the pasture dry
matter we talked about a little bit last
week and I don't don't feel like I left
with a very good so dry matter is the
dry matter equivalent of our pastures
dry matter typically is around 14%
moisture that's self stable for grains
and for Hayes so we figured dry matter
based on that so if a cow eats three
percent of their body weight in dry
matter a thousand-pound cow that's 30
pounds of dry matter per day the thing
we have to remember is this time of year
our grasses are really wet our forges
are really wet they're ninety percent
points so that means that they have to
eat a whole lot more pounds of forage
to cover that dry matter need so we
convert everything to dry matter because
we don't know what the moisture content
of the forage is we know dry haze dry
matter but we don't know our forages so
when we're talking about how much it cow
eats we always convert it to dry matter
residue or residue there again my
challenge to everyone to leave a more of
a residue residues what we leave behind
us so that four inches that we left when
we when we move the cows or on our
livestock on in a cornfield the residue
is the leftover corn flour that's coming
through the combine I maintain we should
come up with a better term in that
residue still sounds like waste to me
that sound like what we what we want to
leave behind and it takes grass to grow
grass and if we leave that residue we'll
have grass next time if we take it all
we won't have gas when we're ready to
come back to it the spring flush
something we're going to talk about in a
web presentation here coming up if
you're looking at that percentage total
gross by month chart down below it's the
Green Line it's that first real big bump
in our forage production we're gonna be
hitting that here in a couple weeks when
everything seems to be putting on a seed
head we can't get ahead and we can't
graze enough grass the cows physically
aren't eating enough grass that's the
spring flush conversely the summer slump
follows that up it's the time of year
when the forage is just kind of stopped
growing typically brought on by lack of
water it's thought that it it's heat
related but it really is more a lack of
moisture even though those are are some
of our wet or months it's that we have
so much heat that our water around here
turns to humidity and is in the air and
not in the soil and not feeding the
plants stockpile we talked a little bit
last slide about stockpile forage would
be forages that we've grown for the
purpose of grazing later in a time when
forges aren't actively growing so that
could be it's typically the fall and
winter but also could be the summer
slump we could be doing
all grass grazing in that summer slump
area and in plugging something we talked
about this time of year bugging
basically is when we've grazed a pasture
that was too wet we had livestock in a
pasture when it was too wet their hoof
action has caused the soil to lose all
of its pore space soils always have pore
space for both air and water and if the
cows especially get to chomping around
in a wet pasture they do what we call
hogging them up and that is that they
leave hoof tracks and they they push out
all the air and water and pore space and
so the plants have nothing left to grow
on the microbes are even going to be
severely affected because there's no air
for them to get in the soil I wanted to
talk just a minute about animal units
and how they pertain to our grazing
system so an animal unit typically is a
thousand pound beef calf we talk about
an animal unit we're talking about a
thousand pound beef cow and so we
convert our actual cow weight down to
thousand pound beef cow range and we can
talk animal units with dairy cows that
typically we're factoring it down to a
thousand pound cow for the CAFO units
and for permited livestock operations
there's whole charts on what is an
animal unit and it's all converting
those animals to what a thousand pound
cow would do that way we're converting
two things one what that animal eats and
two the manure that that animal produces
all to one standard unit of measure so
and we unit follows along with what we
talked about with dry matter you know
it's kind of a conversion ratio for us
so the animal unit day is how much
forage and animal if we're talking about
animal unit day we're talking about how
much forge that they will consume in
that day's time same with a animal unit
month are our soil surveys are typically
put in there for production under animal
unit months so that's anim it's time
thirty days to make it months of
production so I know in the western
states that use a lot at AUM Xan au DS
to talk about how much forage is out
there if they're renting pasture or if
they're figuring out how much they have
under a center-pivot irrigation system
they talk about animal units and animal
unit days then the carrying capacity
could be the carrying capacity for our
entire operation could be carrying
capacity for a particular set of
paddocks or product or one paddock for
that matter but a carrying capacity is
the standard set unit for for an area so
a lot of the grazing leases in the
western states are under carrying
capacity they've got a set number of
livestock and typically they go back to
animal units for for what that carrying
capacity is on that particular piece of
pasture and a grazer
I threw grazer in there as a an animal
in the animal unit category but it
really isn't grazer is us it's it's the
farmer or the producer that is managing
their animals in a grazing situation as
I said I had to cut some slides so
grazer within another one but I put this
in here because every time I spell it
out I get the big red line in spellcheck
and I just want to put that out there
that I'm not misspell in it that is
actually considered us that's us the
grazers and anyone that manages their
livestock in in a grazing way can be
considered a grazer so just a minute
here on some what I consider marketing
terms now I know if you're eating down
through there is saying well those are
management terms and they are some for
some of us it's lifestyle choices our
farm style choices but to me I tend to
put these in a marketing type category
because this is how folks choose to
market their products I guess I put this
in here because I end up seeing a lot of
things on social media and out there in
the community where folks are poking fun
at one Marketing Avenue or another and I
is calling it back it's all marketing
we're all in this together
2% of the population or less our farmers
and so we don't have any room to kind of
worry about how someone else chooses to
market their product these are marketing
avenues they're ways for us to market a
product so organic organic is is a done
by a certifying agency you have to be
certified organic to sell organic
products now there is a loophole there
where you can sell less than so many
thousand dollars and call yourself
organic but for the most part those
folks are certified they've got a
certifying agency that looks into what
they do and an organic typically are not
allowed to use certain products if
they're not naturally derived so one of
the things we run into is is we can't
use treated fence posts sometimes with
organic things because that's a not a
naturally derived product Organic to
gets into the discussion of pesticides
you know they're not allowed to use a
lot of the pesticides that you do use
some the ones that they use are
typically naturally derived pesticides
they don't use a lot of synthetic
fertilizers but they do use a compost or
or other things natural kind of follows
along with that organic type thing then
the natural and I'm not sure whether
they're natural even had whether they
have their own label or not I'm not
really up on that but the natural folks
typically tend to to say that their
stuff is pasture raised so pasture
raised poultry or hogs on pasture
they're considering that they're natural
because there there are some folks that
raise organic products that raise them
in a more conventional setting but they
they use an organic feed and follow some
of the organic practices so the the
natural folks are kind of
differentiating themselves away a little
bit by saying that it was naturally
raised and then grass fed and grass
finished kind of is a sticky situation
sometimes as they started marketing
products as grass fed we found that that
some producers can say well it was grass
fed it had grass or had forage but it
was also fed a
Green product one way or another and so
the grass-finished has then kind of come
up from from there to denote that the
product or the the livestock was
produced using only forage typically is
what the grass-finished would would say
conventional then is is the conventional
way of doing things with they're
following a conventional kind of way of
agriculture and doing things in the
conventional way and that's not to be
derogatory of the conventional folks I
firmly keep myself on the fence on all
of these marketing what I consider
marketing terms because I see merits in
all of them I think all of them have
some good points and all of them work
for themselves and and and that's why I
consider it marketing because it's it's
all in what works for that operation and
how they manage their operation how its
used to market their product well that's
a wrap for this web presentation I hope
I helped you guys have a little more
understanding about some grazing terms
and some definitions for them win this
presentation by thanking our sponsors I
hope you guys enjoy what we've put
together here also while I'm here I'll
say don't be afraid to go look up some
of these grazing terms if you enjoy our
web presentations there are really good
YouTube videos out there about a lot of
these topics that you can pick up and
watching and some there's even whole
series of them and I've kind of done
that here in this time that we seem to
be faced with quite a bit because it's
nice to just sometimes turn off the news
and pull out a good YouTube presentation
and boy have I really learned a lot over
the last few weeks just doing that
whenever I got a chance and really
excited about the spring grazing season
and what we've got coming up here
especially with all the newfound things
that I've kind of been watching reading
through be looking for our virtual
pasture walk next week I believe we're
going to start shooting some
Oh's for it tomorrow and try to get it
put together and turned out next
Thursday so thank you all for watching
we'll see you next time